derek thompson work from home is here to
stay uh that's something that uh he's
thinking deeply about and so what does
that mean for
uh organizations you're saying look
second-tier cities are probably going to
have
some new people which i agree with uh
you're going to see a bit less
centralization uh of
talent and human capital and
organizational energy yeah i do get the
sense that a lot of the big orgs are
shrugging and saying all right you want
to live there i guess we'll work with
that like they're losing that particular
tug of war um how do you feel about
the continuation of remote work are you
positive negative neutral i talked to a
lot of people who are negative on it
just to share that where people who run
organizations
unhappy
people obviously people who for example
run restaurants and retail
establishments in some of these areas
unhappy like how do you feel about it
i think that it depends on who you talk
to and there's a bunch of different sort
of spectra that you can look at right so
one of them is a psychological spectrum
uh introverts versus extroverts the
introverts wow you're getting deep here
derek wow continue i'm starting here i'm
starting here so like the introverts
that i know are so so happy with remote
work like they go to the office and what
do they experience in the office people
are consciously trying to talk to them
they're constantly trying to people
always yelling at them and bullying them
you know just being like freaking
introvert and then like taking their
their trapper keepers and throwing them
on the ground is that the way it's going
all of this all of this yes and so
they're thinking like it is so much more
calm and happy when i'm at home like my
mental health has never been better so
they're obviously happy to stay home and
not commute into an office where they
can be you know assaulted with um
impromptu conversation at the same time
the exercise was assaulted with
impromptu friendliness
definitely talking to an extrovert right
now
um i i would consider myself somewhere
in the middle i look i and i should also
say like for for the the briggs meyer
down
i mean you've
you're probably an introvert that's like
a general thing rule of mine's like if
someone had the patience to sit there
and write a book they're probably
introverted but continue you've written
you've written twice as many books as i
have sir so um i don't know if you would
consider yourself an introvert i am an
introvert anyone who who saw me as a kid
would know i'd just be sitting under a
tree reading some dragon lance now well
you know it wasn't exactly
so yeah the extra verses i know in my
life are like get me back to the office
like i get i get confidence yeah i feel
good about myself when i'm talking to
people so that that's that's no one to
lord it over in their house they just
start yelling at their dog
being like listen to me i have thoughts
but speaking of you know thoughts over
your dog
i i also think that another spectrum
that's important is like um like lower
level employees mid-level employees and
managers right so i think managers want
to get back into the office
for the most part in my experience like
they they enjoy managing people in like
a live setting people that are kind of
advanced in their career but not
managers they're happy to work from
anywhere like they're really really
happy to have that freedom to not have
the commute
younger workers i think
feel often like they're missing out on
culture if culture to them is just a
group slack if it's just like if the
office just becomes
a group text
that's not
an office that's
a group text and so i think that for
some like younger employees they aren't
getting
necessarily the cultural experience that
they want so i think it cuts a lot of
different ways and you know remote work
is one of these things that i sometimes
compare to like like food like it's
ridiculous to say that food is good or
bad some food is good for some people
some of the time and that's what we're
going to see with remote work that it's
it's going to be this unevenly
distributed thing that works for some
people and not for others and it's going
to be particularly difficult i think for
ceos who are managing large companies
that have a
wide spectrum of psychological profiles
introversion extroverts a wide spectrum
of workers young middle-aged and old
that's where the where the you know
what's really going to hit the fan
because i think it's just going to be
really difficult um to
to find a solution that works for
everybody
well i'm really with you derek and that
the people that i feel bad for are the
young workers who are coming up because
if you just came out of school and you
were trying to figure out how to prove
yourself in an organization
uh it's i think it's just harder or
to get a sense as to
how to manage people also probably
harder because you know you aspire to
try and become that manager at some
point i'm going to share something there
is a 20-something-year-old in my life uh
you know like a family member who's been
working from home
and i think is getting depressed as a
result
um now if you were to ask this person
hey would you prefer remote work or
going into the office they would say
remote work
now do i think that the remote work is
getting them pumped up on a day-to-day
basis or even developing them
professionally not really
but if you ask them their preference
they still would say well i prefer
working in my sweatpants to having to
commute like get dressed go the office
like do this thing interact with those
horrible other people face to
face or whatever it is like you know if
you uh leave it up to them um
but i'm not sure that their preference
actually matches up to what would help
their uh career over the medium term or
even their day-to-day happiness uh like
and i i'm you know it's like i'm
somewhere in the zone too where like if
you're an advanced professional you can
work from anywhere and you have a family
like i do then you know it's like it
becomes very very appealing to say yeah
let me just beam in um but but i do feel
for that next generation what you're
pointing to is something that the uh the
psychologist dan gilbert has called miss
wanting
he has a book called stumbling on
happiness about
just various ways of thinking about our
eternal search for permanent happiness
which will never actually happen but
that's what makes it so fascinating to
think about and this term is wanting
refers the fact that lots of people
seem to tell themselves or tell
pollsters or tell
their family members that um
they want a particular thing that
actually makes them miserable over the
long haul so i for example have a friend
who has a a theory about rich people
and he says i think rich people buy
loneliness
with their money too often but what
happens when you get really rich you
might buy the private jet okay that
makes sense like no one likes flying in
coach they can fly in first class on a
private jet but they buy a big house
maybe in the middle of nowhere and
they'll buy you know a pierre terre um
in a city and they don't really want to
talk to people so they'll find various
ways to to make sure they never have to
to speak to people outside of their
network and they'll design this
perfectly insulated life that guarantees
that they aren't um what did i say
assaulted by impromptu conversation by
the unwashed masses
and as a result they'll feel
like they're missing something they'll
feel an aspect of isolation and so they
are miswanting
a feeling of eliteness that is actually
conducive to loneliness and so here you
have examples and i guess either end of
the economic spectrum and obviously miss
wanting is not just something that
happens to elites i think it happens to
all of us um you know the the sunday
afternoon that that one spends um
watching eight hours of netflix and then
reflecting back that huh i kind of wish
i didn't spend eight hours inside it
would have been nice to have taken a
walk you miswanted to that that binge to
a certain extent um i do think that much
to netflix's delight
um i do think there's something rather
rather profound about the about the
phenomenon of miss wanting and it's
possible that a lot of us you know
miss wants a lot of conveniences of
sort of interesting it's just friction
man if you ask anyone like hey do you
want friction be like hell no and you
know it commutes friction other people
are friction the office is friction
um but it turns out that some degree of
friction is probably healthy you know
there are people that are trying to
discipline themselves in social media
and they like you know take the app off
their phone so they can't just freaking
pull it up they have to go through a
browser and some other stuff
you know it's like sometimes you
introduce friction
um but you can sell frictionlessness to
just about anyone and say hey do you
want to buy it and be like yeah yeah
yeah um and that relates to the
isolation factor too it's like other
people suck do you want to like you know
buy the gate be like yes
no you're a super villain do you want
the floating hideout where no one can
come assault you with their faces
[Laughter]
so it's you know it's something that uh
that i i think we're seeing in in
different ways is just so there's some
friction that we probably wanted that
that would be my case and that might
include some elements of the in-person
office experience yeah the um the
columbia professor tim wu has written
about this uh that there are
certain ways that the
uh tech consumer economy can be so
perfectly frictionless that it can uh
remove some of the sort of the the small
and convenient beauties that are just a
part of life and sometimes i find that
to be too much of a traditionalist
argument but sometimes i think it's kind
of right like i think he was he wrote
this article the new york times about um
at the joy of of wandering through an
antique shop not knowing what you want
that now if you want something what
you're supposed to do is that that's
some funny [ __ ] out of tim what the hell
is that about like you had to choose an
antique store i mean at least my
examples made sense come on tim
i i might be misquoting i hope tim
doesn't get mad at me um but tim's now
like a senior white house appointee so
this is the kind of leadership so we're
in these objectives
tim's a really good smart guy tip's a
really good sport he's gonna stick the
ftc on me um but yeah he was pointing
out that today you want something and
you just type it into your phone um and
you don't experience the friction of uh
of of looking for it um of of having an
exploratory experience i suppose you
could say and we're freaking pen pals
man old enough to remember that [ __ ]
where it takes like a week to get the
letter like that
i don't want this to be too i don't want
to become too fuddy fuddy-duddy like i
am a huge fan of technology i'm a huge
fan of the friction points that have
been eliminated um by a lot of these
companies but clearly like there is
there is something that is wrong we all
we all we all feel it i think in our
bones and we can sometimes see it
literally in the statistics there is
something
wrong with a life that is overly
mediated by our phones or that is overly
mediated by these technologies designed
to produce streams of frictionlessness
you had this graph in in your book
of the coincidence of the rise of
teenage anxiety and depression with the
mainstreaming of the smartphone this is
something jonathan hate has written
about psychologists at nyu a bunch of
other people are on this instagram is
even found in its own internal surveys
uh shocker effect shocker facebook new
facebook new
don't continue
and they're just i i do i do see this
all as you know the all of these stories
is being a part of the same mega story
um that
tech is is awesome um and every and
these these apps are are wondrous in so
many ways um but there is something that
seemed to be removing from our lives
humanity brother
we freaking miss that humanity action
you know you gotta walk
walk down the street and find your
friend as opposed to
seeing their best moments on your phone
and thus screwing with your mind
yeah
you and i are aligned on that point for
sure
[Music]
you